Like people, languages come in families.
No, there aren’t such things as mommy, daddy,
and baby languages, but rather languages that
share common origins and characteristics,
based upon their evolution throughout human
history.
Hi, my name is Luca from LucaLampariello.com
and today I'm going to talk about language
families, and how learning languages from
the same family can benefit (and occasionally
harm) your language learning progress.
So, first: “What is a language family?”
I’ll give you an example:
You might know that there is a group of languages
called the “Romance languages”.
There are many, many Romance languages, but
the most well-known examples include Spanish,
French, Portuguese, Romanian, Catalan, and
my native Italian.
Despite the fact that many people consider
French, Spanish, and Italian languages of
“love”, the word “Romance” in this
case has nothing to do with love at all—instead,
“Romance” means “of the Romans”, or,
more specifically, “related to the language
spoken by the Romans”, which was the Latin
language.
You see, once upon a time, languages like
Italian, French, and Romanian didn’t exist
at all.
Back in the days of the Roman Empire, the
main language spoken in what are now called
Italy, France, and Romania was simply Latin.
Then one day, the Roman Empire fell, and the
Latin spoken in each of these areas began
to evolve, independently of other locations.
The variety of Latin spoken in Italy gradually
became Italian, the variety spoken in France
became French, the variety of Romania became
Romanian, and so on.
So much time has passed now, in fact, that
speakers of these once-Latin languages occasionally
have a hard time understanding one another,
if they can at all.
Italians, for example, have great difficulty
understanding Romanian speech, especially
without the aid of writing.
And vice versa.
So, in a nutshell, that’s what a language
family is: a group of languages that evolved
from the same ancestor language.
And language families can have multiple levels,
as well.
Modern Greek is not a Romance language, but
bears many similarities to Romance languages
because its ancestor, Ancient Greek, was a
sister language to Latin.
Latin and Greek (and many, many other languages)
actually evolved from a common ancestor language
known as Indo-European.
English is a descendant of Indo-European,
as well.
Other well-known language families include:
The Germanic languages - German, Dutch, Swedish,
Norwegian, Danish, Icelandic, English, etc.
The Slavic Languages - Russian, Polish, Czech,
Bulgarian, Macedonian, Serbo-Croatian, etc.
The Sinitic Languages - Mandarin, Cantonese,
Shanghainese, etc.
There’s a lot more than that, but I think
you get the idea.
So why are language families important?
Why should you, as a language learner, spend
any time thinking about how languages are
related to one another?
Language families are important because in
most cases, it is faster to learn multiple
languages from the same family than it is
to learn the same number of languages from
completely different families.
In other words, knowing about language families
can make it easier for you to become a polyglot.
There are downsides as well, but let’s first
dive into the benefits:
1 Shared Linguistic Features Are Easier to
Master
In general, learning languages from the same
family is easier because languages within
the same family share many similar characteristics
with one another.
Exactly which characteristics are shared will
vary from language pair to language pair,
but it’s fair to say that any similarity
is possible.
By this, I mean that languages within the
same family can share:
Vocabulary
Syntax (word order)
Morphology (word composition)
Grammar
Pronunciation
Tone/Intonation
and more.
Once you’ve expended the necessary effort
to learn one language within a family, you
can then choose to learn a related language
with one or more of the above shared characteristics.
When you learn this related language, it will
be much easier for you to master the shared
element, since you already did all the hard
work with your previous language.
Let me give you an example:
Polish is a Slavic language.
When I started learning Polish in late 2011,
I could already speak Russian, which is also
a Slavic language.
Since I knew Russian well, I was already familiar
with the common features that all members
of the Slavic language family share, such
as the aspect of verbs, the form of words,
native Slavic vocabulary, syntax, and needless
to say, the case system.
For that reason, it was easier and faster
to learn Polish in 2011 than it was for me
to learn Russian in 2004.
Knowing Russian already meant that I could
learn a lot of Polish “for free” (that
is, without expending a lot of effort).
2.
You can understand other languages of the
same group without speaking them.
Within the same language group, there are
some languages that are closer to others,
and in different ways.
For example, Portuguese is surprisingly similar
to Spanish when written, but surprisingly
different when spoken.
In particular, the pronunciation of Iberian
(Portugal) Portuguese sounds very different
from any variety of Spanish—in fact, when
I heard Iberian Portuguese for the first time,
I thought it sounded like Russian!
On the other hand, Italian and Spanish are
structurally less similar than Spanish and
Portuguese, but share a very close pronunciation.
So, if you put an Italian and a Spaniard together
in the same room and forced them to speak
to one another without using a common language,
they would probably understand each other
more easily than if you repeated the same
experiment with a Portuguese person and a
Spaniard.
I was able to take advantage of this phenomenon
after I had reached a comfortable level in
Polish.
Once, when I was traveling through Hungary,
I encountered a Slovak truck driver who could
only speak Slovak.
Slovak is a Slavic language, but despite that,
speakers of Slovak cannot easily understand
Russian.
So, to communicate with this person, I had
to resort to using Polish, which is a much
closer sister language to Slovak than Russian
is.
Despite the fact that we were speaking two
different languages to one another, this man
and I succeeded quite well at communicating—in
fact, we didn’t even have to slow down our
talking speed!
An interesting side note to this phenomenon
is the fact that sometimes the ease or difficulty
of understanding a sister language depends
on which language you speak.
As I mentioned earlier, Portuguese and Spanish
are related, but it is often easier for Portuguese
people to understand Spanish people than the
other way around.
3.
Actively learning one member of a language
family can help you maintain your existing
level in other languages within that family.
Language skill is not a static thing.
If you learn and use a language actively and
frequently, your level in that language will
improve; if you don’t do that, then your
level will gradually decrease, sometimes dramatically.
This is one of the main challenges that polyglots
face.
To maintain their skill level in all the languages
they know, they need to find time to practice
those languages.
And there’s only so much time in a day to
do that.
When you know multiple languages within the
same family, however, this challenge gets
a bit easier.
Since languages within the family share many
similar characteristics, actively practicing
one language within that family can help reinforce
your existing understanding of other languages
in the family, even if you don’t actively
practice the others at all.
For example, I currently speak five Germanic
languages: German, Dutch, English, Swedish,
and Danish.
Aside from English, German is the language
of this group I speak most often (I use it
with my coaching clients).
German and Dutch are very similar, but I hardly
ever speak Dutch at all, nowadays.
Despite this, my frequent use of German has
allowed me to maintain a respectable level
in Dutch, and allowed me to use it well on
certain rare occasions.
Ok, and now let’s talk about the the downside
of learning Languages from the same Family
So far, it may seem like learning languages
in families is something that only offers
advantages.
However, as they say, “all that glitters
is not gold”.
There is one main disadvantage to learning
languages from the same group, and it can
be summed up in a single word:
Interference.
What does “interference” mean?
It means mixing up and confusing the languages,
both as you learn them, and when you go to
use them.
Since languages within a family are similar,
but not the same, it is very easy to confuse
them as you go about your learning.
Since you’ll generally always have one language
that is “stronger” and another that is
“weaker” in your mind, the stronger language
will often exert more influence, and make
it harder to “relearn” similar structures
in the new language.
This happened to me with Dutch and German.
When I started learning Dutch, I already spoke
German quite well.
So, whenever I went to use a Dutch structure
that was similar to a German one, my brain
automatically chose the German version.
This led to me speaking an awkward hybrid
of Dutch and German, rather than just Dutch,
as I intended.
For example, I used to say:
“Als ik in Amsterdam was” (when I was
in Amsterdam) instead of “TOEN ik in Amsterdam
was” because in German, “als” is the
word you use to introduce a temporal clause:
“Als ich in Amsterdam war” would be the
German version.
This kind of interference is inevitable at
first, but can gradually be minimized, or
eliminated altogether.
The best way to do this is to learn one language
in the family extremely well (to around a
B2 level) before you learn another language
in the family.
At that point, you will have built a strong
enough “core” in the first language that
the second, weaker language will be unable
to interfere much with it.
Of course, as I mentioned earlier, the stronger
language will interfere with the weaker language,
but as you improve your skill in the weaker
language, this interference will decrease,
and the two languages will grow strong and
independent of one another.
What happens if you don’t earn one language
well before learning another from the same
family?
Massive interference!
Since both languages are not at a B2 level,
they are not strong enough to withstand interference
from the other.
It’s as if they were two young trees planted
next to one another.
Small and weak, the two trees will have to
compete for the same water and air to survive.
If these resources are limited enough, it
is very likely that one or both of the saplings
will die, rather than growing up into big,
strong trees that can survive well, even with
competition.
This is why I always highly recommend that
people NOT learn two closely related languages
at the same time.
Spanish and Italian at the same time?
Nope.
Polish and Czech.
Not a good idea.
Dutch and German?
Not recommended.
You’ll experience massive interference and
confusion throughout the learning process.
Before we go, I want to talk about another
type of interference between languages, which
can get in your way even if you know both
languages well.
I’ll call this interference “blocking”.
I’ll illustrate with a brief story:
I once knew an American girl who had moved
to Italy after living in Spain for three years.
Upon arriving in Italy, she was totally fluent
in Spanish, and had no problems using it whatsoever.
When I met her, she had been living in Italy
for one year.
Italian was her main language learning priority,
and she focused on learning it every single
day.
At the time we met, I would say she spoke
fluent Italian.
One time, she told me the story of how she
recently met some Spanish tourists in Rome.
Even though she hadn’t spoken Spanish in
a long time, she was confident in her skills,
and decided to strike up a conversation with
them.
Much to her surprise, when she opened her
mouth, no Spanish came out!
Instead, all she could speak was Italian!
In that moment, she said it was if she was
trying to dig through her brain for the Spanish
she was certain she knew, but all she could
find was Italian.
Somehow, her more recent and ready Italian
skills were blocking her Spanish skills!
This has happened to me too, from time to
time.
As a language learner, it can be quite a shocking
and uncomfortable experience, and is definitely
one of the stranger forms of interference
one can encounter.
Luckily, I can confidently say that this kind
of interference can definitely be overcome.
In the above story, my friend was unable to
speak Spanish because her Italian knowledge
was so much fresher in her mind.
In fact, it had been more than a year since
she had spoken any Spanish at all.
So the problem clearly is lack of practice.
Even if you know two languages in a family
well, if you speak one and ignore the other
for a long time, this “blocking” is sometimes
likely to happen.
The solution?
Make an effort to practice both languages,
as regularly as you can.
If, say, your dominant language - given your
life choices and circumstances - is Spanish
but you don’t want to lose your fluent Portuguese,
make sure you spend at least 10-20 minutes
every day with Portuguese.
You can do this in a variety of ways, be it
listening, reading, or even having a pretend
conversation in Portuguese with yourself!
Best would be to hop on a Skype call or maybe
text chat Whatsapp to keep your Portuguese
capacities alive.
Now, before I finish, I wanted to share a
couple of other tips and make you aware of
certain “traps” you may want to avoid.
First, though learning one language in a family
is highly likely to make learning another
language in that family easier, it is not
always the case.
At the very least, certain structural features
of the language can be different enough to
make learning harder.
For example, though French and Spanish are
both Romance languages, French pronunciation
is extremely different from Spanish pronunciation.
So if you know Spanish and expect to learn
French pronunciation quickly and easily, you
may be sorely mistaken.
And another thing you may encounter when learning
multiple languages within a family is a decline
in interest as you learn more languages.
Since you’ve already mastered one or more
languages within the group, gaining knowledge
of other similar languages may seem less challenging
or exciting to you.
In certain cases, this could demotivate you
and cause you to stop learning the new language.
That’s what happened to me when I started
learning Romanian after learning French, Spanish,
and Portuguese.
Since Romanian would have been my fourth Romance
language, it didn’t seem as exciting or
exotic as many of the other languages I had
my eye on.
To make matters worse, I had no connections
with Romanian people at the time, so I wasn’t
particularly motivated to find a way to learn
it.
So to wrap it up, languages are grouped in
families.
Languages of the same family share similar
traits.
Learning one language within a family means
that in most cases, it will be easier to learn
other languages in that family, as well.
For this reason, if you want to become a polyglot,
it can often be a good idea to learn multiple
languages in the same family before moving
on to other ones.
There are downsides to this however, so if
you want to learn multiple languages in this
way, you should follow certain strategies.
For example, I highly recommend you learn
a language to fluency (B2 or even better,
C1) before moving on to other languages within
that group.
Don’t make the mistake of trying to learn
two close languages at the same time, or you
will likely confuse them.
Even with the right strategy and right timing,
a certain amount of interference - be it syntax,
pronunciation, or vocabulary - is inevitable.
This problem, however, can be easily solved.
The more you learn and speak two similar languages,
the better you will be able to keep them separate.
If you’re in this situation, make sure you
use both languages on a daily or weekly basis,
and make sure you invest some time in clearly
distinguishing and practicing the two different
sound systems.
What about YOU?
Have you ever learned languages of the same
language family?
Did that help or get in the way?
Share your story in the comment section below!
Also, remember to check the article in the
comment section below: I have added more examples
and resources to help you delve even deeper
into this topic!
If you enjoyed the video, be sure to like,
subscribe and hit the bell to be notified
whenever I publish another video on this channel.
As always, thanks for watching!